tú
[Música]
buenos días damas y caballeros y niños
de todas las edades el nombre de julián
amorín y la ciencia en mi pasión y más
que
la ciencia en sí es hacer que la ciencia
sea agradable para todos y motivar a más
y más niños jóvenes y adultos a que les
guste la ciencia interés hablamos de que
si la ciencia es divertida sí y hay
muchos científicos que lo han pasado muy
bien con la ciencia ya por el 1780 por
ejemplo joseph priestley quien sintetizó
el óxido nitroso se usaba el óxido
nitroso el gas hilarante para llevarlo a
las fiestas y si entonces la pasaban la
pasaban muy bien a partir de los
experimentos que ellos habían hecho y
eso también se hacía con la idea de
hacer que más gente conociera conociera
la ciencia y también hace un tiempo
un ingeniero pasando como nos ha pasado
a muchos que de repente estamos pensando
y antes era más común que agarrar una
moneda
agarramos una moneda y la ponía
a girar y si la pones a girar y
observamos como este giro de la moneda y
así pasamos a veces el tiempo pensando
pero este ingeniero empezó a pensar
pero
bendito y entonces observando desarrollo
junto con un su amigo
eso que le llamo el disco de euler el
disco de euler es una relación
giroscópica prácticamente en el que el
disco empieza a tener relación con la
superficie con la que ésta empieza a
generar debido a que está completamente
pulido y como no tiene casi fricción
entonces el disco se puede pasar mucho
tiempo ahí este se desarrolló como un
como un juego pero en 1951 hay una
famoso o famosa foto de james bond
jugando con wolfgang pauli con este
juguetito que tengo acá este juguetito
se le llama el tipito sí es decir el qué
esto digamos que se le llama en español
peonza y en buen chapín sería un trompo
sí entonces este trompo si ustedes se
dan cuenta el disco de euler debido a
sus propiedades de la fricción se
mantiene girando girando y girando mucho
mucho tiempo está ayudado por la
gravedad y por su diseño entonces él
el típico acá yo le puse unas flechas
entonces las flechas están en este
sentido entonces cuando yo lo pongo a
girar
el tipito se da la vuelta y aparte de
eso que sucedió para dónde van las
flechas
del otro lado que quiere decir que las
flechas vayan para el otro lado que no
únicamente se invirtió no paró y empezó
a girar para el otro lado pareciera ser
algo que no creemos de hecho cuando les
digo a la gente que eso sucede me dicen
nada eso no puede ser no puede ser está
para para el mismo lado entonces hasta
que ya con las flechas lo pueden ver y
si ustedes tienen ahora cámaras de alta
velocidad entonces ustedes lo pueden
tomar con su cámara y se dan cuenta que
entonces el trompo eso es lo que le va a
suceder entonces no lo digo si la
ciencia uno la puede pasar muy bien de
forma
bieber divertida
tan divertida como
una explosión
y que me recuerda a mí que en una de
nuestras presentaciones un niño se
acercó y nos dijo noman y nos acercó él
estaba en el público y él exclamó lo
bueno de ser científico es que no puede
ser explosiones y si realmente verdad
pero las explosiones cualquier cosa que
nosotros hagamos nos tiene que llevar en
la docencia a captar la atención y
explicar algo entonces qué es lo que
tenemos acá
dos pistas y fricción tanta fricción que
esa fricción hace ese calor que la
pólvora que está adentro se queme pero
que en la fricción
mejor sintamos la mano contra rápido
rápido rápido que sienten calor porque
la fricción o el rozamiento produce
calor esta fricción que produce el calor
hace que tengamos chisperos como ese es
con el que nosotros podemos prender
cualquier cualquier mechero
si ustedes alguna vez
les han dicho de que el fuego como se
puede hacer pues nos dijeron que si tú
tenías dos maderas las frutas las
maderas y puedes obtener fuego eso no es
tan fácil o tan tan tan fácil
aquí podemos hacer hacer fuego y lo dice
muy fácilmente con mi encendedor si
somos más tecnológicos lo pude haber
hecho también con un encendedor de
plasmas y aquí lo que tenemos es un arco
es un arco de plasma
me recuerda a mí que este juego la
historia de un mi amigo panadero con que
hacen el pan los panaderos
con harina en 3er tenía su harina y su
horno que era de fuego con el que él
siempre había trabajado ya en la harina
le parecía inofensiva pero qué puede
pasar con la harina y el fuego
que si la harina se hace una nube de
polvo la harina puede prender fuego es
la razón por la cual los molinos los
hilos donde se guardan los granos
explotan a sí porque los granos se están
moviendo generan este polvo y este polvo
de harina va a incendiarse y van a
explotar porque están completamente
cerrados
entonces nosotros en ciencia
y motivar a la ciencia hace que tengamos
personajes como este que no sé si
ustedes lo conocen
si quién será
merlin el mago merlín pero el mago
merlín le decían mago porque en su época
lo que él hacía la gente no lo entendía
yo se le llamo magia pero me linero un
colega le da científico también el
alquimista en esta época éstos esos
químicos merlín era quien educaba arturo
y merlin le dice a arturo el
conocimiento y el saber es el verdadero
poder
y poderes que estamos acá tratando de
tener más y más conocimientos porque
nosotros
cuándo
vemos que aquí a la universidad viene
gente con pocos conocimientos viene
gente con medianos conocimientos y tal
vez podría haber que tengamos con
bastantes conocimientos pero que
queremos hacer nosotros con la ciencia
nosotros quisiéramos realmente en
ciencia que poco a poco haciendo
demostraciones haciendo lo mejor
esas tres diferencias fácilmente las
convertimos en que ya no existen verdad
sí por eso es que la motivación para
hacer si esto si si es magia porque si
la volvemos a hacer así pues o realmente
quedan quedan como estaban verdad pero
no son herramientas para que simplemente
para llamar la atención y un hacer
algunas analogías analogías que por
ejemplo
si yo tengo acá
recuerden sé que esto es es ciencia no
ahora sí son las máquinas están en todas
la primera
entonces si nosotros colocamos este
líquido acá
en este nuestro recipiente y lee
prendemos fuego
aquí
entonces acá no si sabíamos lo que iba a
pasar porque porque lo que agregamos si
fue realmente un combustible y ese
combustible se pudo quemar muy pero muy
fácilmente ahora si yo quiero tener si
no no tengo esto la electricidad así
como como ya les mostré el encendedor de
plasma también tenemos este artilugio
que nos sirve para defendernos verdad y
entonces se genera alto voltaje sí pero
de una cantidad de corriente muy pero
muy baja entonces solo llega el músculo
y lo que hace es que nos paraliza pero
como estaba realmente pues yo no quiero
paralizar a nadie pero utilizamos uno de
estos para hacer otra cosa
agarro está mi botellita hago lo mismo
con el combustible le ponemos un tapón
verdad
lo hagamos por acá
ponemos
s aquí es acá y lo que vamos a tratar es
de darle un chispazo le voy a pegar
no nos asusten no atinó verdad que por
allá ya está mejor
e
entonces una pequeña explosión causada
con un poquito de
un poquito de etanol y utilizando una
chispa pero como esa chispa
como la podíamos obtener pues haciendo
una pequeña modificación a un
paralizador como el que tengo como el
que tengo acá si yo vengo
y cuando hablamos del fuego los
elementos del fuego que son calor
oxígeno y un combustible eso quiere
decir que necesito calor entonces si yo
pongo acá por ejemplo
estos
cielos
entonces yo puedo pensar que si tengo
hielo y el calor es uno de los elementos
del fuego entonces yo no voy a tener no
voy a tener ahí fuego
y no
maps
buscamos un poquito acá y vamos a ver si
si obtengo fuego de esta forma y como
les digo acá los experimentos no siempre
no siempre salen así que vamos a
cambiarlo por acá
esperábamos que tuviéramos
esto que tengo aquí
colocando estas piedrecitas colocando
un poquito de agua
cerrándolo y espero que estés y no me
juegue rudo
y lo que estoy tratando de formar es
un poco de acetileno
job
y se aprende donde no quiero ahora ahí
está entonces esa es una lámpara de
carburo de calcio es una
es una lámpara de minero el problema que
tenían las lámparas de minero es que la
llama es abierta y como la llama es
abierta sin la mina había metano
explotado en verdad fue tan que mucho
tiempo después
otro científico
davis hizo su lámpara que lo que hizo
fue protegerla con un cedazo es muy muy
fino para que para quitarle el calor y
eso le salvó la vida a muchos pero
muchos mineros
entonces el carburo de calcio véngase
otra vez para acá
le decía que si nosotros ponemos
este poquito de agua se empieza a
generar
el acetileno
si ponemos esto acá
y los tacos
regresamos espero que haya un poco de
acetileno aquí y si había un poco de
acetileno
[Aplausos]
y esas explosiones por ejemplo
el acetileno se utiliza junto con el
oxígeno aquí tengo yo hago como si fuera
un recipiente un cilindro de oxígeno
voy a ponerle
un poco de líquido acá pero si un
cilindro de oxígeno
de repente se cae que puede pasar
que sale despedido ese cilindro
exactamente igual que se fue esto de
plástico si entonces la válvula está que
yo le puse que es una válvula como ésta
que es lo que hace que la presión así
que eso se vaya acción-reacción y lo
tenemos para allá pero si esto por
ejemplo en un hospital se cae va a botar
tres paredes fácil y si son de tabla y
eso 10 se lleva el hospital
entonces todo lo que sean
con los gases en recipientes cerrados
como este si yo lo cierro
cualquier recipiente cerrado con el
oxígeno líquido al calentarse el oxígeno
el nitrógeno líquido se expande y se
expande el nitrógeno se expande
setecientas veces su volumen por una
taza de líquido va a tener 700 tazas de
gaseoso entonces si yo
le decía en un recipiente cerrado
recipiente cerrado como este
lo cierro acá
lo pongo en ese mi camión para ver si
hace alguna explosión
pero el nitrógeno líquido está a menos
196 grados centígrados es decir que está
muy pero muy frío sin embargo si yo
coloco acá nitrógeno líquido pese a la
temperatura que tiene yo puedo agarrar
el nitrógeno invertirlo en mi mano
porque porque hay un efecto que se llama
el efecto leiden frost esto está mi mano
está tan caliente que
se evapora rápidamente el nitrógeno al
evaporarse rápidamente se hace una capa
se hace un colchón de nitrógeno que está
más frío entonces realmente no entra en
contacto con mi piel
si esa es una de las ventajas entonces
esto pues no tiene que ver con la
ciencia tiene que ver digo con la magia
tiene que ver con la ciencia y si como
uno se emociona a uno se le olvida
el nitrógeno hace que por ejemplo este
guante que es muy pero muy flexible si
yo no meto acá
en el nitrógeno
y lo enfriamos más más más más más y más
entonces esos guantes que eran muy pero
muy flexibles que le van a pasar
que esos guantes en un momento dado
se fractura y esto fue lo que le pasó al
challenger el chalé tuvo una fuga de
ellos tienen hidrógeno y oxígeno líquido
en sus tanques hubo una fuga se super
congeló y al super congelarse entonces
uno de los embarques se fracturó y así
fue como nosotros tuvimos el accidente
de el challenguer este mi vaso que tengo
acá que es blanco pues también con un
poco de ciencia le podemos cambiar el
color solo para que pongan ahí un poco
de atención
si lo ponemos
en este vídeo
y colocado
colocamos jaja
[Música]
pues algunos pensaban que no iba a
estallar sí sí es verdad
[Música]
bueno acá creamos
este serpentín lo que está haciendo es
que está calentando el nitrógeno acá
está saliendo nitrógeno líquido acá se
calienta y sale que es como se usa en
los hospitales el oxígeno líquido sale
como oxígeno líquido pasa por un
calentador y este calentador ya hace que
nos llegue en forma gaseosa verdad
entonces si yo quisiera
colocar
cuántos globos podría yo meter
en este micro pues tal vez uno
y medio tal vez
pero qué pasa si lo empezamos a enfriar
si yo no en frío
y lo enfrío más
y un poquito más y pongo otro más y
pongo otro más
y otro
y otro más
y así podríamos poner
muchísimos entonces qué es lo que pasó
con el aire que había dentro será que el
aire se salió
veamos qué es lo que sucede
no simplemente cambio de volumen el aire
sigue estando allí pero los gases cuando
se calientan aumentan su volumen como ya
vimos con la explosión verdad
el aire sigue estando ahí si yo agarro
uno de esos grandes temas pequeño lo
vuelve a enfriar en frío en frío en frío
en frío y cuando lo saco y lo nuevo
eso que escucho que es oxígeno líquido
sí por qué porque teníamos ahí el aire y
uno de los elementos que vamos a tener
es el oxígeno
como ya nos más que pasamos vamos a
poner este globo acá y este globo acá
que fueron los que hicieron
el accidente del gen denver
que en lugar de tener el yo porque en
esa época no teníamos el yo entonces no
sé si alguien sabe qué gas teníamos
hidrógeno entonces no se acuerda qué fue
lo que pasó
con ese gas
qué es lo que puede pasar con el
hidrógeno
y el fuego perdón
que las tarjetas rojas me puso nervioso
una pequeña explosión y como no hay
mucho oxígeno adentro de él entonces la
explosión es bastante pequeña pero
la bomba que se forma es bastante grande
verdad así que muchas gracias espero que
les apasione la ciencia
[Música]